[Music]
for
e
[Music]
for for
Christian
[Music]
for e
hello hi welcome welcome y'all come on
in so good to see everybody my name is
Rachel my pronouns are she her um so
excited you're here with us today um
next Sunday is the first Sunday in
August whoop where my teachers and
students at it's coming close I'm so
excited I really can't wait to see my
kids uh I'm so glad you're excited me
too maybe I'll see you there uh first
Sunday in August means it's time for our
community meal uh our first Sunday
community meal and we're going to be
doing another pot look so um there's
going to be a QR code up on the screen
so that you can um sign up for a dish if
you would like to we will also post that
link in the at the table Facebook group
if you have not joined that yet um next
we're going to have one of our special
guests Kelly come up and tell us about
an amazing Camp opportunity for lgbtq
youth
Kelly a lot of hyp that's a lot of hype
hey everybody how y'all doing um so my
name is Kelly rabay I am the wife of a
pastor which I never thought I would say
uh my wife is Peppa pag
uh I'm here today to talk about Camp
Haven I brought some flyers that are
really cool uh this is a camp that is
based uh in therapy which is so amazing
uh I'm not a big proponent of therapy
until I went to this Camp so Camp Haven
is a specific camp for LGBT youth uh
there it is up on the screen there uh 12
12 to 17 we do group therapy every day
they're a Therapist assigned to The
Cabins um it's very intentionally done
so having this type of camp in the
community is pretty amazing um I came
back very changed from it um it is about
the kids it is about getting them tools
to help with anything they may be going
through uh the therapist sent it to go
boox home with the kids so it's pretty
incredible uh it is a regular Camp it
just happens to have all of the people
that go are LGBT are fierce fierce
allies so um go ahead and uh do the next
slide please yeah our mission statement
is there uh that's part of the website
uh that you can go to and find out more
information about this uh Camp was
started by a gentleman who came out when
he was 40 never had a church to go to
never had any kind of Camp to go to it
was his vision to create this he did it
um and it's pretty incredible the the
site is beautiful cabins are air
conditioned which is a big plus for me
they have a microwave and a refrigerator
in them very cool for me as well uh next
slide please uh registration opens up
next year March 1 so that goes for kids
and adults always looking for volunteers
so if you want to hear more about it
brought some flyers they're on the table
over there or come by and see me after
worship and I'm gonna hand the mic back
to Rachel thank you so much yeah
Kelly thank you so much um July has been
our season of kind of downtime here at
the table um just to facilitate a Spirit
of rest and recuperation giving our
meetups um leaders a break as well as
Brett and Maggie and Mindy some of our
staff um with that in mind we've gotten
to have some incredible guest speakers
and worship leaders filling in tonight's
a real treat we've got Josh and Joe
Brock leading worship and we've got
Reverend Peppa
panaga yes um with us tonight she's
going to be speaking um so let's take a
moment to quiet and Center ourselves and
really be present here and
now now we exit the kingdom of noise
hurry and
productivity and we enter the kingdom of
Silence Stillness and simplicity a
Sacred Space a space for prayer worship
and
adoration a space to behold Christ
revelation of God and heartbeat of
creation allow The unforced rhythms of
Grace to find you and to your heart may
we all come
home you said there we go hey uh my name
is Josh this is my wife Joe uh we're
gonna be leading some music tonight so
if you'll join us and
stand uh we'll start singing
[Music]
before I spoke a word you were singing
over
[Music]
me you have been so so good to me
before I took a breath you breed your
life in
me you have been so so kind to
me oh the
overwhelming
NeverEnding Reckless Love of God oh it
Chase lives Me Down fight till I'm found
lives the
99 I couldn't earn it I don't deserve it
still you give yourself
away ohy
overwhelming
ending re love of God
[Music]
how is
your steal your love heart from
me you have been so so good to
me and I felt no wor
you paid it all for
me you have been so so kind to
me oh the
overwhelming
NeverEnding Reckless Love of God oh it
chases Me Down fight till I'm F leaves
the
99 I couldn't earn it I don't deserve it
still you give yourself away oh The
overwheling
NeverEnding Reckless and love of God
[Music]
you won't kick down you won't tear down
coming after
[Music]
Shadow coming
after you won't down you w't down coming
after Shadow you will light up Mountain
you w climb up coming after me
Sall you won kick down you won't tear
down coming after
me shadow you w't light up Mountain you
won climb up coming after
meall you won't kick down won't tear
down coming after
me the
overwheling
NeverEnding Reckless Love of
God it chases Me Down fight till I'm
found the
9 I couldn't earn it I don't deserve it
still you give yourself away oh the
overwhelming
ever
[Music]
love all right we'll go ahead and
dismiss the kids you guys can go out
this door over
here looks like I know we have Brock and
Amanda in there I think Katie's stepping
in
she's
excited also if y'all just hear my
guitar stop playing because I am stopped
playing it's because I'm trying to swipe
too just keep singing I well we we'll
get right back into
it oh my
goodness okay we're gonna transition
into prayers of the people so you can
see there's some red up there we will
read that all
together and then we'll come to a point
where there will be some silence and you
can speak out some names or situations
that you want um to pray for all
right for the city of saxi Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and will to conserve it we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to
you for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you for the
vulnerable the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you
for those experiencing loss loneliness
and disconnection and for those
struggling with mental and emotional he
we pray to
you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to you
[Music]
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts we pray to you that they may have
life and light healing and hope peace
and a deep sense of your presence amen
[Music]
I lose my
ability to be
afraid when I see the way you love
me all the fear that H my Fe to the
floor it don't hold me
anymore when I see your
[Music]
face Everything Changes in the radiance
of your
smile you got this
way chasing away those
Shadows that hang
around Lord I
fall
down
again I'm finding out just who I
[Music]
am I've lose my
ability to be afraid when I hear you say
my
[Music]
name all the voices that once fill my
head they are gone when you
[Music]
speak when I see your
face and everything changes in the
radiance of all smile
[Music]
you got this
away chasing away
those
Shadows hang
[Music]
around Lord I fall
down
again I'm finding out just who I am
Lord I fall
down
again I'm finding out just who I
[Music]
am goodbye fear goodbye
shame
goodby
pain I have heard the
father Call My Name goodby running
goodby hiding goodbye
heaviness
lying new has come the old is washed
away hello joy and hello truth hello
love longed for
you I've waited for this
moment all my days hello Mercy hello
peace you have found me on my
knees I I'll never be the
same when I see your
face and everything changes in the
Radiance to your
[Music]
smile you got this
way chasing away
those Shadows that hang
around when I see your
face and everything changes in the
radiance of
[Music]
smile you got this way
of chasing away
those Shadows that hang
around Lord I fall
down
again I'm finding out just who I am
Lord I fall
down
again
I'm I
am hello joy and hello truth hello
love
you I've waited for this
moment all my days
[Music]
mighty one the
Lord calls to all the Earth from the
rising of the Sun to the place it makes
his
b he calls his
people and we will listen
he will not keep
silent until we feel the fire
again oh till we feel the
fire
again let's do that again the mighty one
the
Lord the mighty one the
Lord call to all the Earth from the
rising of the Sun to the place and makes
his bed he calls his
people if we will
listen he will not keep
silent until we feel the fire
again oh till we feel the
fire again
[Music]
a
thankful heart prepares the way for you
my
God the
thankful heart prepares the way for you
my
God come fall on us we fall on you a
thankful
heart will be our
Rhythm come fall on us we fall on
you thankful
heart be our song
[Music]
the mighty one the
Lord calls to all the Earth for a heart
that would bow down for a head that he
live with eyes of
Mercy a burning
passion he will not keep
silence until we feel the fire
again oh until we feel the fire
again
oh the thankful heart prepares the way
for you my
God a thankful heart prepares the way
God come fall on us we fall on
you
thankful
heart we our
Rhythm come fall on us we fall on you a
thankful heart
be our
song Come fall on us we fall on you a
thankful
heart will be our Rhythm a come on us we
fall on you we
thankful
heart will be our song
our
creator has come and meet us here from
the noises of the
outside may we all take a
breath and breathe in some
peace may we hear goodness from Peppa
tonight thank you amen if y'all can have
a seat meet the people around you say hi
to your
neighbors thank you so much Josh and Joe
that was beautiful beautiful thank you
for the time and preparation and
everything you put into that it was
yes it's been great this month to have
uh new and different worship leaders and
guest speakers it's really been a treat
um and a joy this is the last Sunday in
July it's hard to believe uh for those
of you who don't know me my name is
Karen Miner I'm one of the founding
members here at the table and as Rachel
mentioned during the announcements uh
July is our time of rest
and it's such a gift to be able to send
our pastor Brett his wife Maggie and
Mindy our worship leader out for an
entire month just to
be so nice so many so many people in
Ministry do not get time like that and
it is important to us that they get that
and I also want to acknowledge that
there's a whole slew of other volunteers
behind the scenes that make sure the
church keeps going that includes our
kids ministry volunteers our Tech folks
um worship people set up tear down our
greeters our Meetup leaders that are
still some of them still meet a little
bit during July or at least have some
social stuff going on so I'm really
really uh grateful to all of them for
being here during July as well and hope
that they take some time another month
or week or day at least for some rest
and refreshment as
well so it is my privilege and pleasure
to introduce our guest speaker tonight
um and I'm going to read a bio that uh
she provided to me and then I'll add a
little bit of of my own at the
end Peppa panaga pronouned she her is a
pastor facilitator educator innovator
writer Advocate and Ally she is
passionate about thinking outside the
box and inviting others to encounter
experience and embody the extravagant
love of God growing up between the
Redwoods and the Pacific Peppa believes
that as much can be learned by placing
your bare feet in the sand and listening
as can be learned from any book
amen Peppa is a proud and loyal 49ers
fan and loves a good story a good road
trip good food and good coffee Peppa has
learned to Faithfully follow God's lead
as she has now lived more than 18 years
in Texas which is approximately 18 more
years than she ever
planned Peppa has a history in church
planting as well as traditional Parish
Ministry and she is currently serving as
the coordinator for innovation of new
ministry development at Grace presbyter
a regional office of the Presbyterian
Church
USA some of you may also remember Peppa
from the becoming a better Ally Workshop
she facilitated for the table back in
January and I know Peppa to have this
wonderful combination of kind
compassionate and passionate heart as
well as just amazing knowledge and
wisdom for for us for Christians and is
very very generous in sharing that you
are very generous and you're also a very
very good connector I've seen this a
connector of people a connector of
thoughts a connector and just to help us
raise our eyes uh to see a bigger
Kingdom out there and to expand the
Kingdom so will you help me give Peppa a
warm welcome as she comes to share with
[Applause]
us thanks for those kind words
um okay we're gonna hope this doesn't
just like automatically drop that has
happened to me in other places so I'm
just gonna speak it into staying up so
hi everybody um I'm Peppa it's really
great to be with you all both in the
room and those of you who are online at
home or wherever you're watching from
hello so as Karen said um I am not a
native Texan so thanks for letting me
still come and hang out with y'all even
though I am not will not and can never
be a Dallas Cowboys fan um sorry we good
we good no lightning striking good so I
grew up in the Bay area of California so
I lived through the
1989 earthquake so for those of you who
were not born in the 1900s that was a
very large earthquake Where parts of a
very known Bridge the Bay Bridge
collapsed and it was a very big deal I
have vivid memories I was quite young um
but I have vivid memories of my swimming
pool going back and forth in the
backyard and I remember asking my mom
why are there gorillas on the roof so I
knew what to do in an earthquake because
from the time we are starting preschool
they train us on what to do and where to
stand and how to stand and how to
protect your head and body if things are
falling I also because I grew up in
California know what to do when there's
a
fire California gets a lot of
wildfires but the life of this
California your girl was never prepared
for the power and danger of a Texas
thunderstorm so my wife can attest I
have been in multiple cars at the times
of storms funny enough she's never been
with me I have always been by myself I
have had a car total in a hail storm I
have called her from Dallas when she was
safe and Allen and said this is where I
am on the highway and there's a really
big storm cell coming through and I
don't know if I'm going to get to you
mhm it's fine I don't love storms but we
have a hail dent repair friend who will
often call us and say make sure Peppa's
car is parked in the garage because if
it's there we'll all be
fine I'm always in a storm so I am one
who takes the weather really seriously I
am one who looks at the skies who is
preemptively anxious all the time if the
like weather goes from green to yellow
or if we get above a level two my
anxiety goes way up so in our story that
we're going to hear tonight from
scripture I just want to name it's a
story about a storm it's a story that
may feel familiar and it's a story in
which I completely identify with how the
disciples respond to Jesus so we're
going to hear our scripture together or
we we'll read it together I'll be the
one speaking it all right perfect on
that day when evening had come Jesus
said to them let us go across to the
other side and leaving the crowd behind
they took him with them in the boat just
as he was other Boats were with them and
a great Windstorm arose and the waves
beat into the boat so that the boat was
already being
swamped but he was in the stern he being
Jesus and he was asleep on the cushion
and they woke him up and they said to
him teacher do you not care that we are
perishing he woke up and rebuked the
wind and said to the Sea peace be still
and the wind ceased and there was a dead
calm he said to them why are you afraid
have you still no faith and they were
filled with great awe and said to one
another who then is this that even the
wind and the Sea obey
him would you pray with
me gracious loving God calmer of storms
calmer of our
hearts be with us now in this time where
we will hear your word for all of us
tonight God help me to get out of the
way so that your voice and your word can
be heard just as you intend for each and
all of us tonight in your name we pray
amen so I think in this story as some of
us might be settling in like this might
be a story that you've heard
maybe once or twice maybe does it sound
familiar mhm so I know that coming in
there are a lot of times where I hear
scripture read and I'm like okay what
you got that is going to be different
than what you might have heard before so
before you get too comfortable I do want
to say I'm hoping that maybe there might
be a different reading than what you've
heard before maybe the same thing that
stopped me and made me pay attention
differently will speak this story in new
and interesting ways to you cuz here's
the thing I think there's more to this
story than Jesus modeling and non
anxious calm presence I think there's
more to the story than Jesus just
needing a nap as I read the story
preparing for tonight my mind and my
heart stopped on a different spot than
it has before and I saw an interaction
that I hadn't paid attention to so as we
come to the story we have the disciples
who have just given up
everything and they're probably feeling
just a little bit vulnerable as they
step into this boat they're trusting a
man who has asked them to give up their
careers their families to give it all up
to come and follow him and they're now
crossing a sea with a proverbial Captain
who's taking a break from directing and
settles in for a
nap I would not be okay with that just
going to say that the setting is late
and on the Sea of Galilee this is a body
of water that is 680 ft below sea level
it's surrounded by Hills so imagine it
is in a valley and what happens in
valleys wind so this area the Sea of
Galilee is prone to Violent wind storms
and after a long day of preaching Jesus
is curled up in the stern of the boat
sleeping soundly as his disciples steer
The Vessel and according to mark their
boat is surrounded by a small Fleet of
others
and all at once the winds pick up and
huge waves begin to crash on the boat
and season fishermen though they were
the disciples all of a sudden are afraid
for their very
lives Theologian Debbie Thomas says that
all of a sudden what felt like a
cautious risk suddenly felt like a death
trap and the disciples in dire need of
help yelled to Jesus saying Jesus this
is not the way that things were supposed
to go you told us to get into the boat
we were just going to cross to the other
side and now we are in deathly trouble
we followed you we trusted you and
aren't you supposed to do something like
maybe be
awake the only possible explanation must
be that Jesus didn't
care as fear from the movie Inside Out
too would say anxiety would have had a
plan for
that how often is it in those moments
Where We Are are panicked and worried
and when it feels like the storms of
life are battering our proverbial
boats how often do we leverage questions
and assumptions like this at God how
often do we assume that God has just
taken God's leave from all of us in our
hard
circumstances and how often does our
fear our anxiety our worry take the
place of
faith if you're anything like me it is
really often in life when it gets hard
that I start leveraging questions and
lobbying anger at God God can handle it
but it's not my finest
moments it's when life gets hard that I
let my own fear and anxiety start
spinning and making a lot of plans for
my protection because obviously God
isn't going to take care of it am I the
only one that does that okay sound
familiar cool let's be honest the last
few years the last Decades of our human
existence has seen a lot of storms on
global national community and individual
levels it feels like life has become one
storm after another after another after
another and are we just to think that
Jesus would nap through it all and tell
us to have more
faith I think it's totally natural to
read this passage and take the exchange
of questions between Jesus and the
disciples
as the only lesson that one could take
away I think it's a valuable and
insightful lesson otherwise I don't
think so many would have crafted a lot
of sermons about it even books have been
written about this very topic but this
time the piece of the story that I
wanted to really dive into with all of
us is the story and the interaction
between Jesus and the
storm so I want you to just take a
moment if you will wherever you are kind
of settle yourself into to your seat
maybe soften your gaze or close your
eyes I want you to take a deep
breath and I want you to think all the
way
back to the very beginning of
creation before there was land and sea
before there were things crawling and
things swimming before there was day or
night before there was light before
there was anything
it's
here at the very beginning whatever that
beginning looks like in your mind's eye
that God created and
hovered over
chaos over the Earth without form God
created a void watery
volatile dark before light or order or
anything that we can
see God created
chaos you can open your eyes eyes come
back into the space in the
room this chaos was something that could
not and cannot be tamed or controlled no
matter how much we might try it's the
same chaos that marked the ministry of
Jesus as he upended hierarchies
threatened power and principalities and
rested in Rough Waters on rocking
boats chaos was the original creative
work of
God so it's no wonder that Jesus would
not be afraid of the storm and the chaos
that it was
creating Jesus didn't fear the storm but
instead confronted it and said peace be
still and then turned his Focus back to
tending to the
disciples so I want to be also really
clear at this point I'm not going to say
that storms are not worth fearing you
can ask my wife anytime a storm rolls
through I'm
terrified but
remember that in
life fear anxiety sometimes those are
the ways that your body is telling you
to protect yourself so I want to name
that I'm never going to tell you that
fear and anxiety and worry are a bad
thing especially when life is
hard but when I think about the chaos of
this storm on the water and relate it to
the chaos that was created by God at the
beginning of all things something in me
shifts and I can hear Jesus and his
words a little differently not just as a
commandment to be
still but as a compassionate
invitation a reminder of who we are and
who's we
are peace be
still be
still this phrase has resonated with
countless people and has been an
inspiration for wall hangings and
decorative pillows and even the
occasional tattoo and it's a good
reminder especially when the world tells
us to hurry and to hustle all the
time but I wonder if we might hear that
invitation differently tonight instead
of just be
still what if it were be comma
still in many ways the chaos of the
storm is a part of who we are as the
children of God as part of the created
order and maybe we see the storm in
revealed in parts of us that we feel are
wild and
unwieldy maybe it's the parts of us that
we don't show to others the parts of us
that we might even be ashamed to admit
are there
you know those parts that create more
questions than answers and if shared in
in the world could risk making us
different or perceived as
unworthy these are often the parts of
ourselves that we have been told we
might need to
change but Jesus doesn't command the
storm to
change Jesus commands the storm to be
still and it got me thinking what does
it mean to be still or to be comma still
to carry on to continue to be in the
midst of chaos and in the face of the
weight of the world to be in a way that
ushers in peace that can only come when
we feel free to be the selves that God
has created each of us to
be I have to say that this has been a
challenge for me I came out later in
life and I came out after I had been
ordained as a pastor thank goodness I'm
part of the P USA which is an affirming
denomination since about 2018 so it
hasn't been that
long but there are real consequences to
coming out and making the decision to
live my full authentic self to claim the
love that I have with my wife and to
lead in a church that is still figuring
out what that
means I've had to weigh the consequence
of being in a healthy loving marriage
and what that would mean for my
career I have literally been asked in
the storm of life to be other than who I
am there was a lot that I could do to
try to overcome that there was a lot
that I could do to prove that I was
worthy of jobs of hiring there was a lot
that I could do but at the end of the
day the best thing I knew to
be was who God created me to be the best
thing I knew to do was to rest in the
love that I had found with my my
wife ministering from that real and
authentic place has been
costly but it has also been the most
rewarding thing I've ever
done and there comes a point where the
invitation to be comma still in my own
life has meant that I show up in places
and hide neither the fact that I am a
minister or a
Christian and I also do not hide the
fact that I am married to
Kelly and in those ways it has created
space for people to see possibility
where they have otherwise seen
barriers it's given people permission to
wonder if in themselves they too might
be called to be the god the person that
God has created them to
be representation is important I have
learned and when I think about the chaos
of the storm and the invitation for it
to be comma
still I resonate
and I am compassionate toward it and
realize that sometimes all we can do is
be in the face of
hardship it's hard and holy work to be
even when the calm doesn't come when the
Waters of Life stay treacherous when the
storms rage and loss feels profound
being often feels like the opposite
response of
doing but sometimes being is all we have
to do to surrender to choose a different
way to free ourselves from a false sense
of
control to be and to trust that we are
not
alone in the raging storm and the calm
seas Jesus remains in that vulnerable
vulnerable boat surrounded by swelling
and terrifying
water they the disciples were in the
company of Jesus he rests in their midst
tossed as they are tossed soaked as they
are soaked
and maybe that's the hope that Jesus has
for all of us that we would have a
liberated faith that would allow us to
be still and to be comma
still being still in the face of chaos
and being comma I know it's a lot but
being comma still when the chaos brings
us to our
knees I imagine that it's what faith
looks like when Faith goes beyond words
on walls and throw pillows and becomes
etched in the beat of our heart and
grows as close as the breath in our
chest this interaction between Jesus and
the storm is a reminder that we love a
God who insists on being with us and
that a messiah who came down into the
world as Emanuel God With Us is a
grace-filled God who desires
relationship with each and all of us we
worship a God who wants to be be with
us
still let that sink in God wants to
Works to fights to demands to be with
us and has not and will not ever leave
us even when we may not feel God that
close and here's the thing in the midst
of my anxiety in the midst of my worries
in the midst of all of the ways that we
plan to avoid crisis or heartbreak or
even when our hearts are rendered broken
and we are screaming at God in Rage and
anger it actually means that we know in
our hearts that God is there to receive
it God is with us to receive all that we
feel all that we are in our good moments
in our hard moments in the moments we
can't ever understand or explain God is
there with us being being with us
still and scripture is full of so many
stories where God shows again and again
what God is able to
do what God does on our behalf what God
does for us or for God's
people and even when we cannot see it or
when it doesn't look like we think it
should I find Hope in this
story that God invites us all to be
still and to be comma
still all God wants is to be with
us and for us to Simply Be ourselves in
God's
presence the storm didn't have to do
anything to be any more or less than
part of the created order and Jesus
offered it peace inviting it to be
still and that's the same invitation for
us to recognize that who we are is a
reflection of the Divine and that part
of God's abundant creation we are
invited to that same
peace we're invited to rest to be still
and to be comma still as we live in the
Abundant love of God there's nothing we
can do to earn it and there's nothing we
can do to lose it all we have to do is
be and my friend Bruce says that it is
just that easy and just that
hard so The God Who Wants to be with us
offers us peace peace and rest and the
freedom to be who we have been created
to be to feel the things we feel and
that is the same God who calls us
beloved and good and it's here at this
table God's table where we are invited
and reminded again and again that we are
beloved and that we are
welcomed so here at the table we
practice what is called an Open Table
where everyone who is invited where
everyone who wants to is invited to
participate so friends at home I'm also
going to say to you watching online this
is a time to get a little snack if you
want to join us in the active
communion people here in the room we
will start with the front row and move
back just form a single line down the
center aisle and there will be people to
serve you as you come up please note and
this is important the red is real wine
and the white is grape juice and all of
the bread is gluten-free
so in my tradition there are words that
we say before this meal and I've taken
the best of them and I'd like to share
them with you
tonight so before Jesus was arrested and
taken to the Cross he sat at a meal with
his closest friends his most trusted
circle of people he knew one would
betray him he knew others would deny him
but he fed them all anyway saying take
and eat in his final moments with his
friends and what must have felt felt
like urgent and important moments Jesus
was specific and clear about the words
he said to them and he commanded them to
love one another and to remember him in
the bread and the cup
shared and that same invitation is ours
tonight to come and eat to love one
another and to remember
Jesus friends this is the table not of
the church but of the Lord it's made
ready for those who love God and for
those who want to love God more so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have tried to follow and you who have
failed come because it is the Lord who
invites you and it is God's will that
those who want God should meet God
here so friends come to the table
for e
for
[Music]
thank you so much Peppa it was a good
word uh I can't play the guitar and talk
at the same time so I got to stop
playing to address you guys I'm working
on it though uh man what a great message
uh this last song that we picked kind of
ties into to it um I hope it's not too
cliche because it's very direct
correlation to the message um but it is
really a beautiful song um so I invite
you you can stand or you can just sit
and just meditate over the words that
are being sung over the words that Peppa
brought tonight um your choice
um but join us as we close out worship
[Music]
tonight call me out upon the
Water the greater unnown
Where Feet May
[Music]
Fail there are find you in the
mystery in oce
Ste my faith will
[Music]
St and I will call upon your
name and keep leave my eyes above the
waves when o rise my soul will rest in
your
Embrace I am
yours you are my
[Music]
Grace bounds and deepest
wat Sovereign
ha will be my
guide Fe May fa the fear surrounds
me you never fa and you won't start now
and I will call upon your
name and keep my eyes above the
waves when o rise my soul will rest in
your
Embrace I am
yours you are
my oh
[Music]
you are
mine
[Music]
Ohad me where my trust is without
let me walk upon the waters wherever you
would call
me take me deeper than my feet could
ever W and my faith will be made
stronger in the presence of my
savior Spirit lead me where my trust is
Without Borders
we walk upon the
waters wherever you would call
me take me deeper than my feet could
ever and my faith will be made stronger
in the presence of my
savior Spirit lead me where my trust is
Without Borders let me walk upon the
waters wherever you would call
me take me deeper than my feet could
ever
wonder my faith will be made stronger in
the presence of my savior
[Music]
I will call upon your
name and keep my eyes above the
waves my soul will rest in your
Embrace for I am
yours and you
[Music]
are thank you so much for joining us
this evening and thank you again Peppa
for that that was such a gift um if you
are new we would love for you to scan
the QR code that's going to be behind me
um just so that we can say thank you for
being here or answer any questions you
may have about what the table is and
believes um we just want to say thank
you um if you're in need of prayer or a
hug or just somebody to talk to I'll be
here again my name is Rachel I'll be
standing right over there after the
service and I would love to be there for
you however I can um generosity is a key
aspect of a life of adoration and
worship if you would like to give
financially um you can scan the QR code
or visit the taable tx.org
now I'm going to send you um into your
week with a blessing if you would like
to stand you're welcome to um you can
hold your hands out in a posture to
receive or you can just open your heart
to these
words you are a child of
God you are a child of God this is true
on your best day and this is true on
your worst
day so as you go into your week ahead
with it's yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in between go filled
with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted just
as you are and go filled with God's hope
Holy Spirit and the desire to extend
these same Gifts of Grace and
unconditional love to everyone you come
into contact with be blessed and we'll
see you next Sunday thank you
came